Voiceover: These are some
questions that I'm going to
answer for the Financial
Times that they may use in an
article that they're going
to do about the Khan Academy.
The first question; to what
do you attribute your ability
to effectively digest,
synthesize and teach such a
wide variety of topics?
I guess the simple answer is
that I really enjoy doing that
and I think by a set of
circumstances, either by
maybe the way my brain works or maybe just
circumstances or maybe
ways that I've been taught
and I don't remember where
that might have come from.
I learned a long time ago that
there's two ways to get by
in our system and actually
I'll say in our system or
maybe more broadly in society,
you can go and look at
knowledge as something
where you're memorizing
things or you're pattern
matching things or you can look
at it as something to conceptually
understand and digest and synthesize
and I think I was fortunate
enough at an early age to
be much better at the
digestion and the synthesis
than the memorization
or the pattern matching.
I actually think I have
quite a bad memory.
That's how I think I was
able to do reasonably well
academically and then later
on it transferred over into
actually contributing in my work life.
I think there's a natural
high; I don't think
I'm unique there. I don't
think there's a unique
quirk to my personality.
I think when people really
do learn things it's one of
those natural highs.
It's one of those things that
differentiates human beings
from most other animals is
that we really like learning.
We really like understanding
and we really are
naturally curious.
It's actually maybe a little
bit sad that more people aren't
as excited about trying
to digest and synthesize
a wide variety of topics.
Actually just to focus on the second part,
a wide variety of topics,
what's interesting about that
for me and I learned a lot
of this to some degree from
my former jo working for
an investment fund and
analyzing a bunch of
different companies and a
bunch of different
industries is the more topics
you look at, the more that
you see that there are
common underlying themes
and there more connections
you're able to make.
The more you're able to
have a philisophy of how the
world works.
I actually think it builds
your understanding of
every field, the more
fields that you look at and
you're able to see connections.
If you just focus on one
field, it'll actually narrow
your view even of that one field.
The next question; where
does this polymathic mastery
of such varied subjects come from?
There are plenty of intelligent
people who could study
up on these subjects and
not be able to communicate
them so effectively.
A similar answer as the
last; to some degree
the same answer as the last.
I enjoy looking at things,
I enjoy learning things,
and I enjoy thinking.
I like sitting on a park bench
just thinking about things
and you need something to
think about and so that's why
I like studying different
topics and I like seeing where
there might be parallels or
where there might be ah-ha
moments or there might be
magical things about that
subject that maybe
people didn't realize or
maybe emphasize properly.
The second part about not
being able to communicate,
I agree there are plenty
of intelligent people who
could study up on these subjects.
The not being able to
communicate them effectively
I think there are people
out there and I'm hoping
more and more of them do
decide to communicate them
effectively and I'm hoping
we can find them and maybe
they can even join the
Khan Academy faculty.
I think the important that
a lot of people who do
have subject matter expertise,
they sometimes have the
difficulty of getting into
the mind of a learner.
I'll be frank, a lot of the
way I view the world is fairly;
I think I have fairly simple
models in mind and I've
gotten good at taking
complex things and creating
simple models in my own mind so that
I can work with those models.
I think some people are
actually good at keeping
complicated models in their mind.
When you have a complicated
model in your mind,
it's obviously much
harder to communicate them
because it's complicated,
but I think most of those
models can be distilled down
to a more simple and more
elegant ways of thinking about things.
Next question; were you
always drawn to such a
variety of subjects, how do
you maintain your curiosity,
is there anything that
strikes you as too dry to
learn and teach?
Once again, yes, I was always drawn -
Well you know, actually
I'll take that back.
Early in my life there were
two things that I really liked.
I really liked art and
drawing and painting when I
was very early on.
When I was actually in
school, people viewed me as
the art guy, the guy who
would draw pictures and
cartoons and stuff like that
and I really mathematics.
What I didn't enjoy in my
earliest schooling is I
wasn't a big fan of reading
and I wasn't a big fan of
writing in my early school
and I viewed those things
that I just wasn't good at.
Sometimes when I used to
read, I would just sit and
fixate on one sentence and
have to read it over and
over and over again and it would take me
forever to read a page.
It was something that
actually frustrated me a lot.
It wasn't until later that
I kind of, I don't know,
to some degree destressed
how I viewed those some of
those things and I let
myself explore things
without the stress of
judging myself or having
other people judge me that
I started realizing wow,
I actually do like reading and
I actually do like writing,
this is a form of communication
and I love just thinking
analytically about how do
you make an argument.
I think the underlying lesson
there is when you thought
you didn't like something
and then you learned that
not only do you not not
like it but you actually
like it, you're like well maybe
I'm prejudging everything.
The second part of this
question, is there anything
that strikes you as too
dry to learn and teach, no.
There's nothing.
There's things that right
now I perceive as dry,
but my gut feeling tells me
that it's just the way it has
been taught or marketed to the world
that people make it dry.
One of my big discoveries is even
something like accounting.
You tell someone accounting
and they think it's this
dry subject, but I remember
when I went to business
school, kind of this big
ah-ha moment was this is a
really fascinating subject.
It isn't just about bean counting.
It isn't just about bookkeeping.
It's about using symbols
and numbers to reflect a
certain reality of what this
business or this process
is actually doing.
When a lot of people hear that,
they still might say well,
that's not that, but trust me,
it can be very interesting.
In fact, this whole financial
crisis is driven people's
different philosophies or
understanding of accounting.
I think my philosophy and I
haven't had a topic yet that
has disproven this philosophy
is that what's dry is
how the topic is presented,
not the topic itself.
Really almost any topic
can be very intellectually
interesting if it's
looked at the right way.
What do you do for fun? What do you read?
What movies, films and arts do you enjoy
during your free time?
One could get the
impression that Khan Academy
is all you do.
In terms of fun and this
answer has changed a lot
over the last three years
since having children,
so my time is limited now
and I can't do all of the
stuff that I used to like to do.
One of the things that I used
to like to do when it was
just me and my wife or
even before I was married,
I liked the outdoors a lot.
I liked to go hiking.
It's something I hope to
do with my children soon,
but they're a little too
young to go hiking or
camping just yet, but that
is one of the things I really
liked doing, just outdoors things.
I'm a hobbyist guitarist and
painter and I don't claim
at all to be good at those
thing, but they are things
that I like to do for fun.
They're a form of creative expression.
In terms of what do I
read, I read a lot of
science fiction which may
not surprise a lot of people,
so a lot of science fiction
and frankly I also like to
revisit a lot of the books
that I was forced to read,
so to speak, in high school and college.
When I revisit them and
I'm reading them for fun,
I'm starting to really enjoy them.
Frankly, I read a lot
of science fiction and
I read a lot of the classics
for fun and I've found
that they take on a new light.
One, when you read them for
fun, you're a little older
now and you have a little
bit more perspective on life.
Although hopefully, I have a lot more
perspective to get.
Science fiction, they're fun.
They're fun by themselves,
they tend to be good stories,
but they kind of expand
your mind and really
make you think.
A lot of things that we take
for granted in our society,
science fiction books are
really good at exposing them
as somewhat arbitrary and
that there are other ways to
do things and I think there really are.
They are some of the
best things you can read
to expand your view of what is possible.
What movies, films and arts do you enjoy
during your free time?
Once again, I love science
fiction and I love epic
things generally, whether
it's Braveheart or
Lord of the Rings or the Godfather movies.
I don't think I'm alone in
liking those types of things,
but my wife every now and
then gets me to watch an
episode of Felicity on
Netflix and I enjoy that too
which is a little bit embarrassing.
One could the impression that Khan Academy
is all you do.
Well, it's a lot of what I do now,
especially with children I think.
I try to during the day,
focus on Khan Academy,
in the evening focus on
wife and children, but
within that context I try to
at least to have one good
book to read while I'm
travelling or maybe
right before I go to bed.
Now that my kids are getting
a little older I'm getting
a little bit more time to
go back to a little bit of
the outdoor stuff and a little bit of the
creative projects.
What do you want Khan Academy
curriculum to encompass?
Is it K-12 basics on
math and science or is it
broader than that?
Will it ever be complete?
The second answer is easy to answer; no.
It will never be complete.
I think there's an infinite
number of topics to cover and
I think we can always
improve on what's covered
and we can always attack
it from a different angle.
I don't think it will ever be complete.
It isn't just K-12 basics.
In fact, even now it
isn't just K-12 basics.
There's a lot of content
about college level material,
even graduate level material.
There's stuff about economics
and finance and we've
just brought on two
art history professors.
They're the new first
editions to the Khan Academy
faculty and they're doing
art history really at an
advanced level and we're
starting to do some videos
with professors at
Stanford medical school and
other places where we're
attacking even medical stuff.
There's no end and we
really want it to encompass
everything that helps people
form a view of the world
and understand the world
around them and become
productive and happy and people
with rich lives, I guess.
So it's pretty much everything. (laughs)
Next question; as Khan
Academy continues to find a
larger audience, do you
have any concerns about a
growing number of students
learning from one source?
Is there a risk of having
a uniformity of primary
materials for students?
We think about this issue
and this is why we are
expanding the faculty and
there's actually going to be
someone who joins also
on the math side and she
teaches things with slightly
different view, although,
I think we have similar sensibilities.
Our goal is to iterate and
we're actually starting to
get more analytical about
what makes a video good.
If someone makes another
good video on something or
there's another way to view
things, we hope to include
those in the library.
We don't think we'll have a
million different teachers, but
we think on a topic you
might have two or three
different view points on something.
We think that's good.
We're also starting to
introduce across the board
and we've done this with
the medicine videos and some
of the economics videos
is we're starting to have
conversations in our videos.
This is what the two art
historians do, Beth Harris
and Steven Zucker.
They have art conversations,
so it's them two talking
about a piece of art or
me and a professor talking
about some scientific phenomenon.
You're really getting a
conversation and seeing that
there's two sides to it.
Frankly, I think it's better.
You can go to a university that has many
professors, but when you take
intro to American History,
you get only one source.
You're getting that one
professor or there is only one
textbook right now that
dominates each field.
We actually think we can
provide more voices than what
is traditionally provided.
The powerful thing about
the internet now is I don't
think anyone can capitalize
as one voice and if anyone
did, especially if that was
bad quality, they would lose
because the internet gets
rid of all intermediaries.
There's no gate keepers anymore.
It's not like we're a publishing
firm 50 years ago where
only what's published
is what people get at.
Now people can get anything
anywhere and frankly,
anyone can do what I did
over You Tube and people are
and I think that's a really
healthy thing that you can
always get the other points of view.
Next question; why are
you focusing on education?
I guess the simple answer
is, well I guess this may be
all together are you concerned
about public education.
Regardless of whether we're
all professional educators,
we've all spent significant time in the
education system.
I'm no exception.
I did just have a nagging
feeling while I went through
it that there's got to be
a better way to do this.
I saw how many students
were just pattern matching,
how many were memorizing,
how little retention people
have, how many resources
people have, and still not
coming out on the other
side having done creative
things and really
stretched their thinking.
It seems like we're at an
inflection point in history
and this is the information
revolution and it's crazy
that almost every other field
is getting revolutionized
except for education.
I think it's just right
for it and just answering
some of those early
questions about my interests,
it's what I love doing.
I entered the investment
world because I loved learning
about different issues.
I loved talking to an
ag producer one hour and
talking to a railroad
company the next hour and
talking to a software
talking to a natural gas
pipeline owner the next hour
because you'd learn how the world works.
That's what education is,
learning how the world works,
learning ways of thinking.
Sometimes with the goal
of becoming a productive,
happy member of society with a rich life.
I can't imagine anything
better to focus on I guess
is a simple answer.
It's something that's
interesting to me personally,
but obviously it can scale
now and it has ripple effects
that can go on not just
for a few years, it can go
on for generations.
It's one of these epic
ideas and I already told you
I like epic things.
Are you concerned about the
state of public education
in the US?
I'm concerned about the state of
public education everywhere.
In fact, I'll say I'm
concerned about the state of
education everywhere.
Franky, people dump on
the public schools a lot,
but I don't think the private
schools are much better.
They're selecting for
students who would probably
do well if you gave them a
textbook and who come from
college educated families
who are wealthy, who can
afford private tutors.
They charge them out here in the Bay area
$30,000 a year.
I don't know what they're
doing with those resources
and I don't see substantially
different results from
private schools charging
$30,000 a year to the public
schools that are serving
the same demographic.
They seem to be about
the same or some of those
public schools are even better.
I actually think the whole
model and it's even true
of...People talk about our
university system as the
best thing out.
They do good research.
That's why they're famous.
That's why they are but in
terms of how they're teaching,
there's nothing that I
find particularly ground
breaking or something that
you can't improve upon.
I think there's a lot that can be done.
I'm actually concerned
about the general state of,
actually when you say
education, I'm concerned about
the general state of
people's learning in life,
irrespective of what the
education system if doing.
What are your thoughts on
the importance of primary
education as a means to a productive
and prosperous society?
That's what it's all about.
If you don't have that
primary education, there's no
way to have a productive
and prosperous society.
You need basic security, you
need basic infrastructure
and you need an educated population.
It's now true more than ever.
Back in the old days,
there were jobs where just
raw labor was relevant,
but with technology that
becomes less and less relevant every day.
In order for people to be
productive and to contribute
and to feel needed, they really have to
step up the chain.
Raw labor is needed
less and less because of
mechanical technology and because of
informational technology.
Processed oriented white collar work
is also going to go away.
It's just going to push
everyone, the really
needed jobs are the highly creative ones.
It's not good enough
just to teach people some
process or some formula
or some pattern matching.
We have to teach them to be creative,
we have to teach them to innovate,
to problem solve things that
they've never seen before.
Yes, I think it's not just an ingredient.
It's actually the foundation
of having a productive and
prosperous society.
Last question; is it your
hope that Khan Academy can
help reverse some of the
losses we have suffered
in the quality of public schooling?
Just going to the previous
education, I don't think
it's about public schooling
or private schooling or
primary or secondary education.
I hope it can help elevate
the state of knowledge
or learning generally
and I won't make any bold
claim that we've solved
the problem yet or we're
anywhere close to it, but I
think what's exciting about
Khan Academy is that we
have a lot of traction and
we're trying to be as
thoughtful about improving
on what we have.
You combine the traction
with our ability to iterate,
move quickly and improve and
hopefully in a thoughtful
way and we can only get better.
I think we're really just
in the top of the first
inning and there's a long
way to go here, but I'm
hoping that it can
improve the state of how
people learn generally.